[Music]
the european parliament has elected the
maltese mep roberta metzola as its
president for the next two and a half
years
mitzola came out ahead of two other
women candidates alice barkunke from the
greens and sirarego from the left
metzola from the center rights group the
european people's party is the third
woman the first maltese and the youngest
person to hold the position speaking
after her election she said parliaments
would defend european values
honourable members
our house
matters
it matters to our judges under attack
to our healthcare frontliners under
pressure
to every woman in our union still
fighting for her rights
to the vulnerable
to the oppressed
and the abused
mitzola also says she wants to give a
sense of drive and passion to girls and
young women
first elected to the parliament in 2013
metzola is a lawyer by profession before
becoming an mep she held several posts
as legal advisor within the eu
including in the office of high
representatives for foreign affairs
catherine ashton
as first vice president she took over as
acting presidents following the
unexpected death of david sasoli at the
beginning of 2022
[Music]